hey guys today we're gonna talk about
the eight major benefits from prolonged
fasting now prolonged fasting is where
you'd go 48 72 hours or longer sometimes
a week sometimes 21 days sometimes even
longer
there's some interesting benefits that
occur when you do this the body goes
into this survival mode it's kind of
like a physiological vacation for your
organs especially for your digestive
system because every time you eat you
kind of like shut down that system the
people that eat frequently let's say
you're doing three meals plus two snacks
never have a chance to get these amazing
benefits let's start with number one you
actually regrow your brain cells not the
entire brain but very specific parts of
the brain including the hippocampus
parts of the brainstem and other parts
as well so that's really cool I mean how
many of you could use some extra brain
cells so the part of the hippocampus
that's regenerated has to do with memory
okay there's like a relay switch in
there that helps you get access to your
database your memory your file cabinet
of memories so you're able to regrow
that structure of the brain to improve
memory that's really really cool okay
number to increase mitochondria the
mitochondria are the energy factories of
the body so you're gonna find that your
energy goes straight to the roof
incredible amounts of energy when you
don't eat well remember you're burning
your fat so you are eating
you're just not eating dietary calories
number three at Apogee this is a
condition in your body whereby it
recycles old damaged proteins okay and
other things like microbes in damaged
mitochondria so it's kind of a good
self-cleaning action going on and you
recycle these proteins into new proteins
to build new tissue this is the epitome
of anti-aging but in order to get in
this you you want to do prolong fasting
now I do recommend doing in a minute
fasting once a month or once every other
month or even like four times a year
would be great all right next one is
enhanced stem cell production the stem
cell is the cell without a purpose
it's not differentiated into a specific
cell yet it just sits there and until
the body says I need a new cell because
this is damaged or it needs to be
replaced and you actually get new cells
as you age stem cells go down the more
stress you have the more sugar you eat
or the more frequently you eat the more
it goes down so when you do prolong
fasting you actually enhance your stem
cell reserve your pool of stem cells and
this is another reason why you would get
younger and you would feel more youthful
because you have more replacement so
prolong fasting is a really amazing
repair action the drugs that promote
anti-inflammatory effects basically
dominate the market most of the money
and drugs have to do with
anti-inflammatories interesting
rheumatoid arthritis autoimmune diseases
just pain and inflammation this tool of
prolonged fasting is essential to
actually help someone get to the root of
why they're they're stuck in
inflammation a diabetic has a lot of
inflammation so if you have arthritis
bursitis rheumatoid any of the ideas at
all you need to do prolonged fasting all
of the autoimmune diseases involve
inflammation that's why the remedy for
autoimmune whether it's MS rheumatoid
always involved taking steroids okay
like cortisone shots or prednisone and
that's an anti-inflammatory but the
problem is it rebounds and it creates
more inflammation destroys the adrenal
gland so this is a very safe way of
reducing your inflammation and if you
have an autoimmune condition this is
essential you can greatly improve that
condition because the effect on
prolonged fasting on the immune system
number six decreased tumor growth so
whether you have a polyp assist a boil a
fibroid you need to do prolonged fasting
to improve that situation when you get
into fasting you run your body in
ketones and tumors cannot survive with
ketones cancer lives on sugar and when
we do fasting we deplete the sugar
reserves your glycogen reserves and we
were running on ketones okay and fatty
acids well tumors
can't live on that okay so we started
them off and also cancer lives on
glucose and al glutamate so by doing
prolonged fasting you get the starve
cancer as well so that's another benefit
that I didn't mention number seven
increase antioxidants your body has an
antioxidant Network okay so you have
vitamin C vitamin E zinc connect as an
antioxidant glutathione lipoic acid
there's a whole bunch of them so when
you go into fasting your antioxidant
levels go way up why because this is
where the body repairs and it defends
itself against microbes and things like
that but zinc actually goes up when you
do prolonged fasting and zinc is
involved in a lot of enzymes that are
antioxidant your acid also goes up now
you might think that's a bad thing but
uric acid is one of the most powerful
antioxidants in the body that your body
uses when it's fasting so it goes up but
then it will come back down too so it's
not a long-term thing it's just a thing
that will spike up just because because
the body means that to clean up some of
the stuff that it's dealing with okay
number eight cell resistance to stress
so there's been this idea that when you
prolong fasting it's very stressful to
the adrenals well actually it's helpful
to the adrenals because it increases
your stress tolerance you're no longer
running on the ups and downs of sugar
you're basically going into this
interesting repair mode where the body
starts to increase the resistance to all
sorts of stresses and part of that is
the antioxidant level but part of us
just like if you were on chemo for
example and doing fasting your body what
your cells would survive better because
of this fact right here so the cells
become tougher okay it's just kind of a
survival mechanism that's established
from genetically because of years of
adaptation in the past or when our
bodies don't eat it has to survive so it
goes into that certain mode now how do
you do prolong fasting I would recommend
you let your body tell you how long to
fast especially initially you want to
let your body kind of get used to it so
let's say for example the first time you
try you only go 24 hours and you have to
eat that's fine well give it more time
maybe next month start again and maybe
go to 36 hours ok and then work to 48
hours
let your body tell you when you need to
eat ok and I'm not talking about just
some small amount of hunger I'm talking
about like oh my gosh I feel weak my
blood sugars are crash I'm hungry well
of course you're ready to eat ok just
eat but what you'll find when you do
fasting is your your hunger goes away
and you feel good mentally and in your
digestive system so if you're feeling
great ride the wave and keep going the
only time I wouldn't recommend fasting
in general intermittent fasting or
prolonged fasting is it if you're
pregnant
ok or you're breastfeeding healthy keto
is fine but not in a minute of fasting
and the other situation that I wouldn't
recommend prolonged fasting would be if
you're very very thin and you're trying
to gain weight because you're gonna lose
some weight on this so that might be an
issue you can do intermittent fasting
maybe two meals a day but when you start
going more you're gonna lose a lot of
weight so that's just one one point
about that but go gradually and let your
body tell you how long to go so many
people do this they just like they start
fasting and they feel great so they just
keep going going going as long as they
can they might get upset at you hours
and then they're ready to eat ok so over
time you can do it longer and longer and
longer but you don't want to force
yourself what you're living off is your
your reserve of nutrients so I do
recommend taking a multivitamin mineral
ok
I do recommend electrolytes in sea salt
I've had people actually pass out by
trying to do this too fast because they
weren't taking enough sea salt
electrolytes and they just did the the
body needed that so you know make sure
that you don't omit this when you
actually get done with your fast you
don't want to do this huge meal you want
go slowly you want to refeed slowly
because it's kind of a shock to the
system eating too much okay so go just
eat a little bit wait a little bit eat a
little bit more gradually ease into it a
really good thing to do when you're
fasting is green tea naturally
decaffeinated would be good that will
really help increase your antioxidant
level and another tea that's great for
prolonged fasting would be hoodia
gardenia and that will help suppress
appetite so it just makes it even easier
there's a there's a product called EDTA
you can find it online this is a key
letter I like this product because it
pulls out heavy metals specifically iron
and calcium especially if you have a lot
of calcium deposits and stiffness or
kidney stones and a lot of other
minerals but if your iron is too high
you can have a lot of problems with the
body so this is a good peel it or pull
the excess free iron out of the body so
if you took this let's say you took it
twice a week and you just took it in the
morning and then the afternoon you took
your electrolytes that would be awesome
because this does pull out other
minerals too so we want to put the ones
back in that we want but EDTA I
recommend it to take excess calcium out
of your body and excess iron out of the
mitochondria which you're going to find
that's going to enhance your energy even
more it's great for circulation it's
good for cardiovascular function and
also mitochondrial function so it's just
an extra thing that is very beneficial
to take but you just need to take it
like twice a week you don't have taken a
regular basis just because it'll it you
could pull out too many minerals so
there you have it the eight benefits of
prolonged fasting in a nutshell thanks
for watching hey guys I want to
introduce you to my new doctor Berg app
it's right here it's I'm really excited
about it you need to download it it's
free has a lot of great data it has all
my videos it's updated on a regular
basis I also have the audio version of
the videos audio episodes I also have a
mini course that you can take I also
have a button for new content so you can
really know of all the
recent content that I'm downloading and
I also have something called PDF
resources which gives you additional
cool little one-page PDF documents on
all sorts of health things so download
it check it out and tell me what you
think about it and don't forget to give
me a review
it's dr. Berg app